so earlier today I went over the best
gaming laptop deals that I could find
for this Black Friday so here are the
best people gaming PC deals that I can
find just starting off at the very entry
level you have a gaming PC from
CyberPower it has the Rison 5 2600 a
gigabytes of ddr4 ram or 1 terabyte hard
drive and a gtx 1050 TI on top of that
as a nice addition of a 128 gigabyte SSD
it is really nice to get a SSD
especially at this price level and just
makes day-to-day usage much much better
and the rise in 520 600 is a solid 6
quart altered CPU with base clock of 3.4
Gerdes and max turbo frequency of 3.9 a
Hertz usually this PC comes in at $800
but you can get a 200 discount this
Black Friday and get it for 600 bucks
next up for the mid-level section is
another cyber power PC this PC has the
i5 8400 eight gigabytes of ddr4 Ram a 2
terabyte hard drive 240 acre by SSD and
a gtx 1066 gigabyte graphics card over
the last PC you get a boost in hard
drive and SSD storage from 120 gigabytes
to 240 gigabytes and one terabyte to 2
terabyte you also get the gtx 1066 give
a card as opposed to gtx 1050 TI this pc
usually cost $1000 when there is a 200 s
count and you can pick it up for 800
bucks
I was looking for our nice 1070
pre-built PC but after looking through a
lot of pcs the price type is per ton gtx
1070 and GTX 970 TI pre-built are so
small that I really recommend they just
skip the gtx 1070 pre bolts and go for a
GTX 1070 TI pre build this next gaming
PC is a sky Tech gaming Archangel this
PC comes with the rise in five twenty
six hundred eight gigabytes of RAM a 500
gigabyte SSD and a gtx 1070 TI
unfortunately this PC does not come with
a hard drive but you can easily solve
that issue by picking up a two terabyte
Western Digital or Seagate hard drive
from Newegg or Amazon it really is a
very easy issue to solve this piece she
usually cost $11 but again you can get
$10 off and get this for 900 bucks
finally for the high level section
here's another cyber
our pc this pc has a rise in 720 700 X
gigabytes of RAM a one terabyte hard
drive a 120 gigabyte SSD and the GTX
this PC has to rise in 720 700 X 18
bytes of RAM a 240 gigabyte SSD a one
terabyte hard drive and the GT x 1080
graphics card the Rison 727 Rx is an
outstanding cpu with eight cores and 16
threads and base clock of 3.7 gigahertz
and max clock of 4.3 tears which is a
very powerful chip and the GTX 1080 is
also a very powerful graphics card
really the only downfall of this PC is
that only has 8 gigabytes of RAM and
especially with the G check 1080 you
won't have 16 but other than that it
really is a great PC usually this PC
costs one thousand three hundred fifty
bucks but right now I can pick it up for
1,100 and as far as other graphics cards
go the GTHA DTI prebuilt are way
overpriced the same with the RT X cards
and as far as aim the rx graphics cards
go I really couldn't find many great
deals for that by I may have missed them
to make sure comment down below if I
miss any great deals so that other
people can benefit from that also if you
guys liked this video make sure to drop
a like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm Hari I'll see you
guys the next one
[Music]